yes
right now
oh
my contacts
foreign
thank you
foreign
good morning dear
colleagues
sitting is open before we move to the
main item of
this morning I would like to make an
announcement based on the conclusions of
the advisory committee
dealing with harassment complaints
between
accredited parliamentary assistants and
members of the European Parliament and
after taking into account the
observations of the member concerned I
have decided to impose a penalty on
Monica Silvana Gonzalez performance Rule
10-6 and Rule 176 as a result
of her behavior towards 33 accredited
parliamentary assistance which
constituted psychological harassment the
penalty consists of for the first
assistant loss of entitlement to the
Daily subsistence allowance for a period
of five days and temporary suspension
from participation in parliament's
activity for a period of five days for
the second assistant loss of entitlement
to the Daily subsistence allowance for a
period of 15 days and Temple suspension
from participation in parliament's
activities for a period of 15 days
for the third assistant a loss of
entitlement to the Daily subsistence
allowance for a period of 10 days and a
temporary suspension from participation
in parliament's activities for a period
of 10 days the member concerned has been
notified of the decision yesterday and
is entitled to lot an internal appeal
with the bureau under rule 177 the
penalty would be suspended for the
duration of any such appeal
we move now to the next item which is
Council and commission statement
presentation of the program of the
activities of the Swedish presidency
dear prime minister christason dear
colleagues on the 1st of January we
welcomed Sweden at the Helm of the
Council of the European Union
today it is a pleasure to have with us
prime minister
Ulf christusson to present the program
of activities of the Swedish presidency
prime minister jerulf welcome to the
European Parliament questions on the
economy
questions questions on the economy will
dominate The Swedish presidency and I
believe that a return to growth can be
one of your major achievements in order
to boost the economy you stand for an
open Modern and competitive Europe this
is what the European Parliament stands
for too growth will also come from
reforming our energy market and to make
it future-proof efforts must be made to
reconcile energy security with the green
transition Sweden is already a front
runner in this area which will prove
essential when it comes to us wrapping
up the fit for 55 package last year the
European Parliament and the five
rotating presidencies committed to
working in Partnership to find agreement
on the migration and Asylum package
before the next European elections your
presidency Falls squarely in the middle
of this legislature the urgency to make
progress on all the migration files is
becoming very real here too and yet
despite all these challenges the biggest
threat to Europe and our democracies is
still and will continue to be Russia's
illegal Invasion and Relentless
bombardment of Ukraine Sweden has been a
great friend to Ukraine and you have
always been true promoters of Human
Rights and Democratic Values we must
continue to stand by Ukraine prime
minister
Ulf a month and a half ago you welcomed
me and my colleagues the group leaders
in the beautiful capital of Stockholm it
is in this constructive spirit that the
European Parliament will continue to
work with the Swedish presidency on the
many important initiatives on the table
and on behalf of this house I look
forward to working together with you and
your colleagues and I wish you all a
very success for the upcoming six months
you have the floor
[Applause]
modern president thank you so much
members of the European Parliament vice
presidents of the commission
ladies and gentlemen it is a privilege
and a pleasure to be here today
to present the priorities of Sweden's
third presidency of the Council of the
European Union
in short our chief priorities aim to
help make Europe greener
safer and Freer Greener safer and Freer
we have a lot to do together the coming
sixth months times are though difficult
war is Raging Europe a war that has led
to countless of casualties both soldiers
and civilians and to brutal atrocities
but also to an energy crisis and to an
economic downturn
all this will make the coming months
very challenging most of all of course
for all our Ukrainian friends while we
respond firmly to these emergencies we
must also move the eu's political and
lawmaking agenda forward
so far the European response to Russia's
illegal invasion of Ukraine has been
strong United and decisive
in addition to nine sanctioned packages
we have recently increased our common
support Ukraine with a further 18
billion Euro in macro financial
assistance
many individual countries provide
Ukraine with important military
equipment as well and Ukraine and
Moldova are now both candidate countries
moreover the union is on the road to
reducing our dependence on racial fossil
fuels
in the 70s getting rid of fossils was
mainly an economic matter in the 80s and
the 90s it increasingly became a matter
of fighting climate change and now it
has finally also become obviously a
matter of geopolitics and security
over the last few years we have shown
that in times of Crisis the EU really
can come together and exercise
International influence without losing
sight of our long-term agenda
Vladimir Putin's regime
underestimated not only Ukraine but also
the European Union
foreign
as a new presidency of the council we
aim to build on the excellent work of
the French and the Czech presidencies we
intend to continue in The Same Spirit
when we try to seek Solutions in the
council and of course with the
Parliament and the commission
our obvious starting point
everybody's first priority is and has to
be Ukraine
nothing is as important but this is not
simply crisis management this is about
fighting for democracy and fighting for
decency Ukrainian Victory is existential
for Europe and honestly existential for
the whole world
personally
I woke up in Helsinki on the 24th of
February last year at four o'clock in
the morning to the news that Ukraine had
been invaded by Russia that was only a
few hours after a conversation with the
Finnish president Saudi minister
we both during that conversation saw the
obvious risk of War but we also saw the
risk of Divisions between France
European France and Division
transatlantically
however
when the war came and it did the Western
democracies stayed United today the
transatlantic Unity on Ukraine is
stronger than ever
it is a horrific War which has displaced
the third of Ukraine's population and
destroyed half of the country's energy
infrastructure many ukrainians both
soldiers and civilians have paid the
ultimate price for this war
butcher has become part of our
Collective European memory
but history has also made was also made
when president zelinski refused to leave
Kiev and remain in Ukraine with his
government in doing so
he has embodied the country's resistance
on the battlefield but also in the
battle for hearts and Minds Ukraine has
offered hope for all of us who believe
that the rule of people always trumps
the rule of a strong man
while Ukraine's resistance continues we
must now do what we can to make sure
that Ukraine prevails
and that its future lies here in the EU
because if the hope for democracy future
is in Ukraine Ukraine's hope lies with
us
our task is to continue supporting the
ukrainians who are not only fighting for
their independence but also for a
European way of life where right
is greater than might
[Applause]
as president of the council means we
have to ensure the eu's continued
economic political humanitarian and
Military Support to Ukraine for example
we will have to monitor the progress of
Ukraine's reforms on its path towards EU
membership this also means that we have
to start working on solutions for
Ukraine's recovery and reconstruction
together with all our International
partners
reconstructing Ukraine after the war
will remind us all of the Marshall Plan
after World War II
and in this effort Frozen Russian assets
need not only to be part of the problem
but also become a part of the solution
I foresee a very thorough analysis on
the extent to which the Democratic world
can unite in re-using that money to
repair some of the destruction
[Applause]
so our first priority as president of
the council will to be worked together
with the European Parliament to promote
Europe's security by supporting Eugene
and highlight the eu's geopolitical
significance in an increasingly
uncertain world
and when we build security we must also
look at other aspects that are close to
other citizens free movement in the EU
should not mean free movement of
criminal activities obviously there is
much room for stepping up our
cooperation against organized crime
we must also continue our work towards a
common and coherent migration policy
while at the same time managing the
current situation with all tools already
available to us
in times like these the eu's role in
providing security and stability across
all these Dimensions is crucial
another area where the EU has a crucial
role to play is in the green transition
a task that has only become more urgent
in the light of the war in Ukraine
the plan to reduce emissions by 55 by
2030 is vital
to reach CO2 neutrality by 2050 and live
up to the goals set out in the Paris
agreement
in Sweden we are proud of our own
contributions to Europe's shift from
fossil dependent to Fossil free
on the recent trips to Sweden which
shows to show both the conference of
presidents and the commission how
companies such as a battery maker
northvolt or the car manufacturer Volvo
are creating new innovative ways to
reduce Europe's dependence on fossil
fuels
these businesses they want to go to work
they want to benefit from the great
opportunities of the green transition
and they are asking us in politics
domestically and European
to provide Frameworks for their work
and that is precisely what the EU has
been doing for example through the
decisions to prohibit the sale of new
fossil fuel cars by 2035. going forward
we must continue down this path
the Swedish presidency
intends to do its part to strengthen the
EU as a front-runner in the green
transition
we will continue the important ongoing
work on the institutions and make a
conclusion of fit for 55 hour priority
we count on the European Parliament and
we look forward to work together on this
we also look forward to beginning the
work of reforming the European
electricity Market design since energy
from the right sources and the right
price is the foundation of the green
transition
third the green translation touches on
our long-term competitiveness
if European companies are to produce the
energy and make the batteries the
electric cars and the fossil free steel
of the future
they all need good conditions to compete
internationally
from the very beginning the integration
of our economies lay at the heart of the
European project by removing tariffs red
tape and other barriers We have replaced
power politics with a rule-based market
and turned war between our own Nations
into things of the past
for the past three decades the single
Market has fostered healthy competition
and built strong economies and
industries across our continent
removing barriers for goods Services
capital and people have made our
companies better
our country is more prosperous and
and provided consumers with higher
quality and better priced products
the size and the strength of our
economies is also a significant reason
why the EU is such a powerful actor
nowadays on the world stage
thanks to the single market and thanks
to a successful trade policy based on
openness with agreements and
Partnerships around the world the EU is
an economic Giant
despite this
as a union we are not living up to our
full economic potential
our productivity is lagging behind and
fewer and fewer of the biggest firms on
the planet are EU based today we are
spending significantly Less on research
and development than the us or China
and high energy prices may drive
Investments away from Europe
in other words
we are struggling with several
challenges related to the crisis that we
are going through while facing actions
of Partners and competitors around the
globe such as the U.S inflation
reduction act the eu's response to these
developments need to be analyzed and
discussed as a matter of priority
but we must not forget that long-term
competitiveness must be built on strong
companies that are able to survive and
thrive in competition on an open market
in the long term
factors like weak productivity
insufficient spending and r d and high
electricity prices pose great risks to
European competitiveness than lack of
subsidies to production in Europe
if we want to maintain our leading
knowledge-based economies with
Innovative Industries we need to step up
our game
therefore we need a long-term new
strategy on EU level to boost
competitiveness and productivity the
single markets 30th year anniversary is
a very useful starting point for that
work
[Applause]
last but not least
the fourth priority of the Swedish
precedence will be to uphold the Union's
common fundamental values
I would like to pay tribute to European
Parliament for your steadfast support
for the most important principle that
binds us all together respect for the
rule of law
history teaches us that this is a
precondition for our political our legal
and our economic cooperation if we want
citizens rights to be protected
everywhere across the union and the
single Market to function properly the
rule of law has to be upheld in every
country
liberal democracy the combination of
popular sovereignty and individual
rights is also what separates the EU
from other International institutions
and makes more people in more countries
want to join
these values not corruption and cronyism
are what Ukraine Moldova and other
candidates the countries are aspiring
towards
in that sense making sure that we
preserve the rule of law in the EU is
also a way of enhancing our Global
competitiveness and our attractiveness
foreign
there are there are certainly formats
and forums to engage with authoritarian
States but the EU is not one of them
this is and must remain a club of
democracies
in the last few years we have made
significant progress to safeguard the
rule of law in the EU the conditionality
mechanism has been an important new
instrument to ensure that EU funds are
not misused article 7 proceedings have
been initiated and the rule of law
dialogues have shown that all member
states not just a few have room for
improvement as far as rule of law is
concerned
during the Swedish presidency this work
will certainly continue
and in order to emphasize the importance
of rural law we will also organize the
Symposium on this specific issue in
Stockholm in May
when my Czech colleague Peter fiala
spoke to this parliament in July last
year he paraphrased Ronald Reagan in
saying that democracy is never more than
one generation away from its demees
and I agree
if the last few years have taught us
anything it should be that no political
institution can settle with past
achievements democracy has to be
defended and reinvented in both world
and deed
dear members of the European Parliament
six months is a very short time yet
there is so much to do since these
months coincide with a truly unique
moment in Europe's contemporary history
for obvious reasons the only thing I can
promise you all in this room is that we
will do our utmost there is only so much
that my government can control and some
things will no doubt catch us by
surprise they always tend to do
but I can assure you that Sweden will be
a constructive and enthusiastic leader
of the work in the council and the
Cooperative partner that will search for
compromises with all member states and
all institutions in mind
together we will seek solutions to meet
the challenges that I have outlined here
today
the security to climate to
competitiveness to the rule of law and
more
and we will count on you not just as a
counterpart but also as an ally
thank you all for your attention I now
look forward to the debate thanks
thank you very much
thank you very much prime minister and
now on behalf of the commission vice
president please
we're Madam president dear prime
minister honorable members it's a
pleasure to be here to discuss with you
the program of the Swedish presidency of
the council and I wish you prime
minister Christian and your team your
colleagues every success over the coming
six months
and I also would like to wish to all of
you all of the whole honorable members a
happy New Year and let me Express also
my hope that the 2023 will bring greater
peace and prosperity to Europe
but for that to happen we must continue
to put all our efforts into tackling the
far-reaching challenges facing us
challenges which have not disappeared
with the changing of calendar
the commission therefore welcomes and
supports the Swedish residency's focus
on its main priorities
first we must maintain our unity and
determination in supporting Ukraine and
the Ukrainian people against Russia's
war of aggression and the kremlin's
barbaric attempt to weaponize even the
winter
with the conflict in its eleventh month
Ukraine continues to defend its land
with bravery and tenacity
our support likewise is unwavering with
the first tranche of the unprecedented
18 billion Euro support package said to
be disbursed still this month
we continue to work relentlessly to keep
the Ukrainian electricity grid
functioning including by providing
public generators and Transformers under
the EU civil protection mechanism and we
will resolutely support Ukraine in its
reconstruction efforts the international
donors platform that we are setting up
together with our G7 Partners will help
coordinate our efforts here
in addition we welcome the president's
demand for those responsible to be held
accountable and we remain fully behind
the commitment towards Ukraine's
integration into the European Union
at the same time we need to take action
to address the Myriad repercussions of
the war
this means making Swift progress in the
work on security and defense including
via the adoption of the European Defense
industry reinforcement through the
common procurement act and our updated
Maritime security strategy
secondly we must continue to overcome
the energy crisis a consequence of the
war in Ukraine being felt deeply by
citizens and businesses across the
Europe
Russia's effort to Blackmail Us by
weaponizing energy and manipulating our
dependency on Russian fossil fuel
Imports have failed thanks to our
solidarity
we have reached 20 percent in gas
savings and introduce a gas price cap
which when matched with the warm winter
have led to our Storage level being at
83 percent very high for this time of
the year with gas prices now lower than
they've been before the war
thanks to no small part to our work to
accelerate permitting procedures we
deployed twice as much renewable energy
capacity as expected last year
so there is still much to be done work
is ongoing to operationalize the EU
energy platform to enable The Joint
purchase of gas and I had the pleasure
of chairing the first meeting of the
steering board yesterday
in this effort it is vital that we
effectively leverage the eu's political
and Market weight
at the same time we need to further
scale up Renewables which are critical
for our long-term energy Independence as
well as for the green transition as
president from the line said last week
we should aim to double our renewable
energy capacities this year again
this brings us to the third priority of
the Swedish presidency furthering our
work to meet our climate Ambitions we
look forward to the Swift conclusions of
the remaining trilogues for fits for 55
package the beating hearts of the
European green deal and stand ready to
assist the co-legislators as needed
we also count on Swedish presidency to
make as much progress as possible on
other European green deal proposals
including the zero pollution package and
the proposal on packaging and packaging
waste
this in turn will help boost our
competitiveness
in the framework of the 30th anniversary
of the single Market Landmark we
celebrated in this chamber yesterday we
therefore welcome the focus of the
Swedish presidency on our Union's
economic competitiveness a key part of
its strength
we look forward to working with the
presidency on a number of relevant
measures including the review of our
economic governance framework and the
implementation of our upcoming single
Market anniversary communication
our economic relations with third
countries are also important for our
competitiveness and we anticipate making
progress on agreements with several key
Partners under Swedish presidency
we also will come efforts to
reinvigorate the eu's economy through
additional investments in the green
transition under the repower EU
however we must also consider how best
to support Europe's thriving clean tech
industry at the time where others around
the world are taking measures which
could negatively affect our
competitiveness as well as reduce
investments into Europe
for example we are currently working
with the US to reduce the negative side
effects of its inflation reduction Act
but we still face unfair competition
from China's massive subsidies in its
clean tech sector
in response under the Swedish presidency
we will introduce measures including on
strategy grow materials
we also need to update our state aid
framework to better facilitate the
public investment
and finally we are also pleased to see
the Swedish presidency focus on
migration
at the time when migratory flows are
once again on increase a robust
framework for our migration and Asylum
system is vital
we already have many answers to the
challenges we Face In The Pact on Asylum
and migration so we look forward to
advancing on this issue in the coming
six months
honorable members their Prime Ministers
you can judge from my voice it's just a
proof that the weather in kiruna was
called
but I can tell you that the atmosphere
was very warm
and that Spirit of cooperation was very
very strong so therefore I'm very glad
to conclude by saying that all of us in
the commission I'm sure in the European
Parliament are really looking forward to
work with you with your team with
Swedish presidency and I believe that in
the spirit of European unity and
solidarity we will develop we will
deliver for the people in Europe and for
the European Union so once again thank
you very much for the attention and
prime minister all the best of luck for
your presidency thank you
thank you very much vice president
thank you maros I give the flow now to
the leaders of the political group
starting with the Epp group Mumford
Weber
president metzola vice president and
maharashi would be great to to hear
whether you were also part in the ice
hotel or only in the normal Hotel so
that would be okay it was clearly thank
you for the clarification commissioner
dear prime minister Dear Wolf
welcome truly and very warmly welcome in
the European Parliament the Swedish
presidency
you won the elections last year and
formed afterwards a pro-european
government and now your presidency
starts I would say it's a young
government it's a young government and
that means also a government with full
of energy and motivation and that is so
urgently needed for the development on
European level there's an increasingly
absent Berlin and Paris we need more
Stockholm we need your leadership now
and that's why welcome
in 29 and 2009 Sweden last time led the
council it was Europe in the middle of a
Euro crisis facing the most severe
economic recession in decades the
Swedish prime minister Frederick
reinfeld also from the Epp became
president of the council Captain cool
head and steered Europe through the
crisis and on top of this Sweden managed
to reach the deal on the Lisbon treaty
in an extremely difficult moment you
show leadership has been improved to Be
an Effective crisis manager to be an
ambitious agenda said around a credible
bridge builder and that is what is now
also at stake
your predecessors did a great job a
center right Coalition the Czech
presidency already did a lot of good
things fit for 55 free Power EU
migration
and even to first-time center-right
government first time activating the
rule of law mechanism is I think a great
achievement what they did so that is
preparing the ramp now for Sweden
you spoke about the war
and on this question of security for
Europe you already showed leadership
you have taken responsibility and
committed yourself to our European
security you are not only making NATO
now stronger with joining the NATO but
the entire European Union
and I speak here on behalf of the Epp
that's why I let me underline that
the Socialists always opposed in Sweden
to join NATO and at the beginning also
the European Union it was your party it
was Epp who always together with
Christian democrats always fighting for
Europe always fighting from NATO so you
were always on the right side of history
and finally socially under socialists
understood where to go so
congratulations to the Socialists as
well
for us as EPP you can imagine the most
important point is in this presidency
chops chops chops we speak again about
competitiveness and it's about people
when we speak about competitiveness to
being social means above all providing
people with a chop and a decent income
and that's why again thank you so much
for this Sweden is the best country to
do so because you are a European
champion of innovation number three in
the world with Innovative front-runners
like Skype Tetra pack and Spotify and on
top of this your sweetness the home of
the Nobel Prize so that's why Innovation
is in a way Swedish we welcome this very
much and having the challenge in mind
you mentioned already some examples I
can say on artificial intelligence
American firms invest six times more
than European firms and the top 10
leading companies investing in Quantum
Computing are in the US and in China and
not in Europe and that's why we have to
pick up this competition but for us this
also means Ulf that we have to do it on
European level because the member states
have not the capacity the tools and the
resources to do so in addition to
Innovation more has to be done yesterday
we celebrated 30 years of single Market
a great moment but it's not finished the
work but the Telecom sector we can do
more we have to answer the 430 billion
dollar Ira proposal from the Americans
uh competition is good and we like
competition but our competition law and
legislation is outdated we need a reform
on this the creation of global Champions
is so urgently needed and I have to say
that the resistance from commissioner
vestaga for example to allow the merger
of Siemens in Alston was a Mystic we
need these kind of global Champions to
be competitiveness competitive on global
level and finally on this issue of of
jobs
we want to support you on your trade
policy we finally need to ratify seta in
all member states and with the election
of President Lula in Brazil we have to
sign now mercosul that so needed for
Global level but also for us as
Europeans
uh we showed ambition and ambitious
approach on climate change in the last
month we did this together and now we
have to show the same ambitious approach
for jobs creation
and finally a second wish uh very brief
migration we have to continue on this
the checks did a good job we have to
help people in need no doubt about this
you have to rescue people in the
Mediterranean you have to strengthen
frontex you have to build up strong
Border Protection against smartless and
we have to show solidarity on European
level that is what we have to do and
let's use now the momentum to find the
European Solution on migration the
upcoming special meeting of the council
in February is a momentum to deliver the
wolf I'm convinced that the Swedish
presidency will be a success and Dear
Wolf you can fully count on your Epp
group to deliver good luck
thank you very much man Fred
now I give the floor to the chair of the
snd group hiracha Garcia Perez
[Applause]
thank you very much Madam president
welcome to the European Parliament Mr
Christian
the beginning of the Swedish presidency
comes at a time when the European Union
is going through its biggest boost in
the last few decades no one could
imagine the huge leap in the process of
integration with solutions that have
really risen to the occasion and
measured up to the serious crisis we've
been through if 2022 will go down in
history as the year that paved the way
for unprecedented solutions to fight
against raging prices then 2023 has to
be the year of structural Solutions it
has to be the year of structural
Solutions the main challenge of this
year is social discontent if inflation
continues undermining purchasing power
then we're going to have to come up with
a permanent Financial instrument in
order to protect the most vulnerable
businesses and families in the face of
the discriminatory subsidies of the
United States we have to overhaul these
our state aid rules so temporarily in
order to make sure that the Investments
linked to the recovery plan are rolled
out quickly and in order to make sure
that our single Market doesn't break up
to the detriment of the partners with
less fiscal capacity
despite the fact that high inflation is
still harming our population directly
the Swedish presidency hasn't committed
in any way to the social pillar this is
a serious mistake Mr christerson because
if we are to rather it is a if we
achieve the goals of the Gothenburg
Summit of 2017 that is the only Beacon
that can guide us towards a strong
social Europe full of opportunities and
fairness the debt crisis of 28 of 2008
showed that austerity was a failure and
now the energy crisis
as the deaths now of the marginal
pricing system the current electricity
Market where Renewables account for 50
of electricity production cannot be used
as a model for the future we have to uh
carry out a root and Branch reform of
the electricity Market in order to curb
the impact of gas on electricity bills
indefinitely prime minister please make
sincere commitments here before the
European Parliament at the Swedish
presidency will continue leading the
fight against climate change
your government has made statements but
it has also eliminated electric vehicle
subsidies it is making it difficult for
wind power and your far right Partners
in this chamber constantly voting
against the fit for 55 package
directives history does not have one
only path for Mr christerson now is not
the time to be carried away by the far
right in order to fly in the face of
science climate change and Putin's War
mean that we have to clearly and
decisively plump for renewable energy
sources because strategic autonomy which
we've been eagerly hoping for will only
become a reality when the 27 member
states
throw off the fossil fuel millstone
around their necks now defending our
joint achievements firmly are extremely
important we hope you will keep your
promises when you say that you will
speed up the procedures under article 7
in order to hold the authoritarian
course now you represent a country that
is modern Progressive and that has been
a human rights Trailblazer but your
presidencies program doesn't contain a
single reference to women or migrants so
what is your proposal so that half of
the population of the European Union
that is women can continue achieving the
rights that will get mean that they will
get equal opportunities when it comes to
gender equality we will not uh backtrack
the directives on General violence and
pay transparency need to become a
reality in 2023 and your presidency has
its work cut out for it the future of
the EU also hinges on coming up with a
solution to the problem that migrants
face this is a moral imperative we have
to make sure that we don't live through
the disgrace of prime ministers fighting
between themselves when it comes to
rescuing human beings from a certain
death as is demanded by the law of the
sea it's only if we come up with a new
pact on migration and Asylum that will
be able to put an end to the insolence
of the radical leaders that determine
our migration policy
Mr christerson history has shown us that
the breeding ground of uh the far right
is emotions and bogus Solutions
exploiting social discontent is what
national populism movements resort to
and we have to counter this I am
stretching out the hand of the Social
Democratic family so that together we
can boost the Revival of europeanism and
that we can continue making sure that we
come up with unprecedented solutions to
the problems of our citizen citizens
because they we are aware that today
more than ever era strength in Unity
thank you on behalf of the renew group
foreign
we can all agree the Swedish presidency
comes at a crucial time for our Union
we see clearly that families are worried
about the cost of living
High inflation
economic uncertainty
renew Europe's message
we hear you
we hear you
the solutions do not only lie at the
European level but we have a duty to do
everything we can to make people's lives
easier
the best way to fight back is to focus
on Innovation secure the green
transition and build a modern European
and open economy
that's why we are pleased that
Innovation is Central to your presidency
we need Europe's asked that you were to
make progress on trade agreements we
won't grow Europe by retreating into
ourselves
please keep small medium Enterprises at
the Forefront of your mind because we
need to deepen our best assets as you
already mentioned Europe's single Market
if we want to reduce our dependencies we
must ensure our energy security
finalize repower EU and conclude an
ambition States act do you must invest
substantially in this crucial industry
colleagues this weekend with also the
horrors of the Russian regime Unleashed
on civilians
the terrorism in nepro is a reminder of
everything we are fighting against
Russia must be held accountable
we agree with your Commons prime
minister Ukraine's Victory is essential
let's have a coordinated European effort
to ensure Ukraine has the means to
defend itself
elsewhere we see a barbaric regime in
Iran sending weapons to Russia and
executing its own citizens
it's time for the EU to stop up sanction
against Iran sending a powerful signal
and all migration colleagues it's clear
the citizens expect Solutions
stronger new border controls increase
cooperation with third countries our
citizens expect we are in control dear
colleagues an agreement on Asylum
migration package will be tough but the
rewards will be great and we count on
the Swedish presidency to achieve
progress on the main files
Mr Prime Minister
we wish you the best for your presidency
trust that you have a partner in Europe
in this year before European elections
it's time to be bold and to deliver for
citizens
and we look forward
to a speech presidency with the
innovation of Spotify
and efficiency of Ikea thank you very
much
thank you Malik next co-chair of the
green group Philip Lambert Philip
Mr Prime Minister welcome to the
European Parliament
we the greens European free Alliance
have absolutely no doubt that Sweden as
the logistical and administrative
capabilities to successfully conduct the
work of the EU Council of ministers for
the coming six months
however
I need to be very Frank with you
we have grave concerns regarding the
direction which your government will
choose to lead the coming legislative
work
the three parties of your colleague
minority government have certainly
proven time and again
to be loyal and committed partners of
the European project after all it was
the moderates the Christian democrats
and the liberals who together with the
center party brought Sweden to the EU
that's fact
but unlike 30 years ago your government
is now being held hostage by the Swedish
Democrats an extreme right-wing populist
eurosceptic party that is actually the
largest member of your coalition
and despite your claims to the country
your agreement with them gives them a
direct say not just on National but also
on new policies
Asylum and migration
is the most glaring example of that
influence since 2015 the new member
states have been unable I should say
unwilling to find common response to a
challenge that is unlikely to fade away
anytime soon
as a result people have been dying at
all borders in blatant denial of the
values on which the EU is built
and even before taking the Helm of the
council your government has already
renounced any effort to solve this
crisis what is this if not the influence
the direct influence of your
anti-migrant Coalition partner
you may say that at least on climate the
Swedish Democrats who deny the gravity
of the challenge did not dictate the
agenda and the priority given to the
green energy transition is the is indeed
welcomed
but the other issue is crucial to the
preservation of the planet as our common
home are completely absent from your
roadmap is this so surprising when we
know how much the Swedish Democrats
block any serious effort to restore the
ecosystems on which we depend for our
lives and livelihoods
I'm thinking in particular to the urgent
need to drastically reduce the use of
pesticides an issue that your presidency
seems to totally totally neglect
so beyond the nice slogans we will judge
you on what you will deliver and we hope
you will positively surprise us
Mr Prime Minister when we met in
Stockholm I asked you why on Earth you
and your government Partners chose to
engage with a party that is rooted in
nationalism and white supremacism
your flabbergasting into was
because we agree with them on so many
things
your priorities include the safeguarding
of all democratic values and the rule of
law
still you chose to collaborate with
those who threaten these very same
values
so tell me Manfred Weber tell me Stefan
season Journey where will this end
how far are you prepared to follow your
Swedish colleagues in their new
friendships with a party that openly
opposes the values that you yourself
profess in this house
is it your secret dream hope ambition
that the Swedish Alliance will become
the blueprint for the EU after 2024.
I get the floor next to the chair of the
ID group and marcozani Prego Marco
[Applause]
thank you very much Madam president
vice president
prime minister welcome to the European
Parliament
the Swedish president's presidency comes
hand in hand with high expectations at a
difficult time but we hope that these
six months will be about dealing with
the huge crises that we've been up
against the priorities that you've put
on the table are priorities that need a
specific response and we expect this
from you it's not just about dealing
with the emergency situation but it's
about looking to the next 20 30 years in
the structural future of the European
Union now to talk about
the most topical issue
let me mention energy as vice president
said we're in the middle of the winter
it's maybe going slightly better than
what we expected but I believe that's
probably more by chance and because
we've had Clement weather uh
it's more about that than the fact that
we've put effective Solutions on the
table we would like a specific
structural action because gas prices
are
um above the average of the last few
years and this undermines the
competitiveness of European businesses
but it also has an impact on the
survival of our citizens the
independence of our economy has been
affected many have talked about
overhauling state aid rules and I think
that this is something that we need to
tackle but let us be careful because
this is coming at a cost
we're talking about a lot of state aid
schemes that have been adopted in 80
percent were requests that came from two
of the biggest European economies so let
us tread carefully because the
sustainability and integrity of our
internal Market has to be the beacon the
guiding principle in this reform uh
we've talked about migration we've been
talking about it for years we've been
working hard on agreement but we're
focusing on the wrong issue which is
redistribution I hope that the Swedish
presidency will really deal with this
file and think about protecting our
external borders to reduce arrivals this
is the only way we will reduce the
deaths at Sea it's the only way that we
will make the situation on our continent
more sustainable it's only with a lower
level of arrivals that will be able to
deal with this and convince everyone to
talk about redistribution
one last Point we've talked about
Ukraine and the support of this house
has been unconditional to the people of
Ukraine over the last year but there is
someone else who is uh crying for help
and that's the Iranian people they are
suffering they are clamoring for freedom
and we have to listen to them we expect
a very strong action against the
ayatollahs in by Sweden thank you the
ECR group Charlie wemas
thank you very much Madam president
president prime minister Christian
welcome to the EU Parliament
well one thing that we have in common
is that we
support the struggle for Freedom against
the great state but now this big state
is back at the EU level we know that uh
brexit hasn't brought a chance for uh
Brussels to get better no the
centralists have taken over we need to
make sure
that we don't continue this trend for EU
regulations to become more and more
heavy and for the EU to keep determining
more and more of our citizens lives
the idea of the subsidiarity principle
was supposed to prevent the transfer of
power to Brussels but crisis after
crisis is used to pass more and more
power over to Brussels the EU was
supposed to promote freedom and protect
and prevent protectionism but instead
protectionists green investment supports
are being put forward financed by loans
we're supposed to uh defend our own
labor market model but it seems that we
can't defend that the EU is trying to
decide of forests and harness and the
hunting fuels pretty much every other
area
prime minister in Sweden the
moderate party has adopted a realistic
migration policy
but what the
Mrs Johansson's proposals are to
transfer power over migration to
Brussels
if we are to a countries refused to
Refuge to take in their migrant quotas
they're going to face huge fines
government might spend up to 20 billion
in uh fines if they're going to uh
fulfill their uh election promises so we
know that the pressure is going to be
high the UN have got proposed have got
forecasts about migration from the
Middle East and Africa
that would
figures are higher than they've been
since 2016.
we need to be able to Res resist the
migratory pressure of the future we
should not be giving up power over
migration issues prime minister
the big stake is growing here the corona
fund with joint debt
well I mean you could see them here from
the left side all the way across your
own group in the Epp they're calling
for more transfer of power and more tax
raising it at the at the EU level so the
moderates need to draw the conclusions
prime minister I stand up for what I
believe and you can do that too you're a
vote is not just mine would appreciate
it if Sweden vetoed debt for the EU that
would weigh down the future uh citizens
of Europe
we have to put a stop to the greater
transfers of power that are planned we
need to move away from the United States
of Europe we need to defend individuals
Freedom we need to defend companies
competitiveness in Sweden's sovereignty
and I would like to wish you the best of
luck in doing so thank you next to the
co-chair of the left group Mano Aubry
foreign
colleagues the Swedish presidency which
is beginning
shows a fundamental political Trend that
should alert us all a few weeks ago the
right and the Liberals decided to form a
government but that government is
supported by the far right
an alliance tolerated by the Epp and
renewed groups on the right which feeds
through into a total program commitment
against immigrants
anti-muslim obsessions climate denial
we've heard all that just a few minutes
ago from my far right colleague's mouth
the codons sanitar that we uphold in
this hemicycle
would be broken through the extreme
right has become every day
and the Neo-Nazi language of the
so-called Sweden Democrats who don't
really deserve the name is widespread
this codon sanitaire has been broken not
just in Sweden also in France when a
vice president from the uh National is
brought in by macron or in the
situation in Italy with the ex
Berlusconi right and also the
reactionaries
in your country Miss November the
authoritarian drift of Oban and
elsewhere demonstrates this very clearly
you can't play along with the far right
because when they take power they always
refuse to give it up democratically the
Liberals of far-right Alliance becoming
the norm ubiquitously plays out the same
scenario all the time questioning
democracy and fundamental rights and
neoliberal policies
which bring down social achievements the
Swedish presidency program plays the
same tune and I've not seen any change
of Direction having looked at it even
when the economic crisis is plunging
millions of people into poverty once
again however it's uh
austerity orthodoxies that rides high so
it's always praising structural reforms
and putting public finances right
but yes that increasingly undermines uh
Public Services you talk about budget
rules but those are the ones that
brought the European commission to our
15 member states to overhaul their
pension systems in a year or to ask my
country France eight times to
tear apart its pension system just to
make savings and they say we've got to
do this to limit the cost of Pensions in
other words make people work themselves
to death or illness this Bean counting
let me just recall uh
has been flagged up with great
enthusiasm by so many European leaders
that's why in Brussels in Strasbourg and
in the streets you'll find us following
you
we want to put an end to this
stultifying
yokon many Europeans and
if we don't do that it will be either
misery or the cemetery for so many
Europeans
thank you madam president
that is
the Swedish presidency's agenda steps up
the anti-working class strategy of the
EU and the national governments which
torments the people but they realize who
the guilty party is and that's why we
have a low acceptance rate of the EU the
priorities to escalate the war in
Ukraine between the EU NATO
alliance and Russia and with the
accession of Sweden Finland into NATO of
course the objective is to be able to
intervene anywhere and to implement the
orders of the warmongering cfspc DSP the
Strategic
compass and others
now Russia Sweden is a front-runner when
it comes to the green strategy but now
they're told people there will be power
cuts which shows that this strategy
makes the people pay a very high price
so that the profits of the multinational
companies can be guaranteed uh the
people face such problems raging prices
a shrinking income inflation but
Solutions cannot be put forward by the
EU that defends monopolies only the
people can save the people when they
realize what clout they hold demanding
that their needs be met and taking the
path of subversion thank you
thank you and that concludes the leaders
of the political groups I give you back
the floor prime minister to react before
we continue with the round of speakers
three minutes
thank you very much
is what I say for the first round of
debate
let's be speaking Swedish I'd like to
thank you for your wishes of the best of
luck in the presidency where there's
been friendly questions and critical
questions
and
I think that it was interesting the idea
of getting inspiration from digital
Spotify and analog Ikea to Major Swedish
companies
Swedish companies that have been
successful around the world Manfred
there but looked back to the presidences
in 2001 and 2009 different times
different questions different treaties a
very different conditions
but I can assure the Parliament that I'm
drawing good inspiration from both of
those previous presidences and the prime
ministers who led Sweden at those times
let's start with the relationship
between Sweden and the EU for a long
time Sweden had a very doubtful approach
to the EU
if you look at the 1960s and onwards EU
members estate the membership was seen
as not compatible with Swedish
neutrality while many people find that
hard to understand these days the EU
membership at that time was considered
to be contradictory to neutrality my
party was strongly in favor of joining
the EU it was the other side in politics
that was more negative we had a
referendum that produced a clear
response that Sweden should join the EU
from that point onwards
there's only been growing consensus that
Sweden has an important role in the EU
80 out sorry eight out of eight uh
parties are now in favor of eu's EU
membership
before it was five in favor and three
against now
I'm pleased to see that we are in a good
position in Sweden to act constructively
and positively in Europe
doesn't mean that everything is fine it
doesn't mean that all of the different
parties have the same idea of what
Europe should look like and how we
should solve the problems that are
common European issues that's what
democracy is about though both at home
and in this house
I've got a lot of respect for that
security policy has also been mentioned
six of eight parties are in favor of
Swedish NATO memberships only the greens
and the left are against uh Joy changing
Sweden's security policies uh
approach and that's important as we move
into NATO membership
I'll remind you that there are four
parties that have agreed on solving the
major problems we face in Sweden it's a
paradigm shift in Swedish policy
and there are a number of different
areas where Resolute action is required
first of all stopping organized crime
that I'm sure you've read about a
shooting per day explosions every week
no other country in the EU has had
similar problems to Sweden
reducing in migration to Sweden is one
issue
but we're working harder on ensuring
that we better integrate people so that
people have equal chances to do well we
have transformed their energy policies
so that we can succeed in electrifying
our economy
we're investing massively to build new
Swedish nuclear power plants like other
countries in Europe who are also taking
that route
so that we can be entirely fossil fuel
fuel free in good time
so it is a change of course in Swedish
policy
the government that has now been set up
in Sweden
is normal in Scandinavia the similar
systems have been tried out in various
Scandinavian countries since the 2001
Denmark and Finland
then the Scandinavia is one of the
freest most stable Democratic parts of
the world so I feel very comfortable in
the government that I have put together
in Sweden
the single Market is celebrating 30
years that's good but there's more to be
done the digital single Market the
single market for services there's a lot
that still needs to be done particularly
for those countries that have a
service-based economy
the American Ira initiative
brings both threats and possibilities
it is good that the US is back in
working to defend the climate that is
something that we appreciate it would be
worse if they were not doing anything
global global climate cooperation cannot
function without the USA of course we
need China and India as well we need all
of these players on board
that the EU is a climate Hub in the
world is a good thing but it's excellent
that we have the us back on board
it's also important to look at what
China has been doing in recent years
the problem is that European countries
could be affected by these policies
let's have a close look at the
consequences of the American initiative
let's look at the consequences of the
various options we have for taking
action
we need to look at both the short term
and
the long term so we need to respond to
what the US is doing but the short term
is not enough we can't do anything that
would be damaging to our economy or the
world economy in the long term
there are acute migration issues and I
have spoken to Belgium the Netherlands
and Austria in recent weeks
the situation is acute there's an
increase in illegal migration
70 up over the course of 2022
so something does need to be done but we
also need to look at the long term as
well
in the short term
we need to look at the external border
relations with third countries and
returns there's a lot more to be done
the social pillar has also been brought
up it's no secret that Sweden is very
satisfied
to continue to use the wage setting
model that we have used in the past in
Sweden we do not plan to give up a
functioning model
the EU
has a lot of issues where we can uh
improve cooperation in Social and
Welfare policy
in energy policy we've seen a 50
increase in renewable energy in Sweden
we've got a huge increase in nuclear uh
energy in Sweden overcoming decades
ordinary
the most commonly sold cars last year in
Sweden were electric cars now we need to
provide those cars with uh green energy
and a decent decent price with
infrastructure that makes it possible
for everybody to have one so I'd like to
thank you for all the questions and
comments and I'll come back to you later
thank you very much I give the flow now
to Thomas to bear for two minutes
thank you
thank you very much Madam president
vice president prime minister
the moderate party has been a driving
force in Europe
promoting Europe for more than 60 years
as the Prime Minister said we were the
party that brought
Sweden into the European Union
now we have a moderate party-led
government
which is now leading the Swedish
presidency means a lot
it will mean
stronger increased support for Ukraine
it will mean a wholehearted focus on
Europe's competitiveness
we will ensure that the last parts of
fit for 55 are adopted and the
principles of the rule of law will be
defended across the EU
but finally we'll be able to move from
finding solutions to actually finding a
common functioning sustainable European
migration policy
the European Parliament has high
expectations of the Swedish presidency
to ensure that the council also makes
progress
the EU
shares a common external border
most people understand that we need to
cooperate
if we are to
manage to control immigration
and reduce illegal migration but it's
also important if we're going to protect
the people who need protection
these are not easy negotiations that we
have ahead of us
but we have a unique chance to take
responsibility we have to move away from
a situation where people are dying in
the Mediterranean
where there are too few member states
bearing the an unfair portion of the
responsibility
where we have a distrust among member
states and concerns among our citizens
so
that's the Swedish presidency is a
chance to go from words to Deeds thank
you this next is Helen fritzan for two
minutes
so a tall man call me food Madam
president vice president prime minister
well there are always high expectations
in advance of her presidency and for me
as a Swede it's a special moment because
we're now welcoming a Swedish presidency
but I have mixed feelings as I stand
before you today
Sweden is well known at the
international level
for successfully working on the climate
on equality and issues around democracy
and the rule of law
but and it has to be said today Sweden
is run by a right-wing conservative
government
supported by a nationalist extreme right
party
and that means for EU issues that the
Sweden Democrats are going to be
setting the course
for the future work in your speech prime
minister you painted a picture of the
green transition
saying that that was a major priority
issue for Sweden but at home in Sweden
you have clearly given up on climate
objectives that's why the Sweden
Democrats are saying all policies in the
EU climate has to be negotiate and
negotiated with them before these
proposals are allowed to continue on to
the next level
so will Sweden continue to lead the
climate transition for decades Sweden
has been at the top of the list for
equality indexes
we are one of the most equal countries
in the EU and the Parliament started
his time in government by scrapping as a
successful feminist foreign policy that
we've been pursuing
Parliament didn't sorry the Prime
Minister didn't mention the word
equality in his speech
I work hard in the uh equality committee
here in the parliament it's a difficult
time with crises and we need political
courage clear leadership and responsible
decision-making
there are concerns out here in the
Parliament and I'm looking forward to
the government
that is now leading
the Swedish presidency and will create a
stronger EU where we take Joint
responsibility so good luck in your work
of christerson thank you very much
for one and a half minutes
Madam president prime minister
commission members
Sweden is taking over the uh the
presidency of the EU turbulent times
there's a war in Ukraine there's
inflation and crisis hitting the whole
of the EU but it's an important time
citizens across our Union
trying
to find Solutions and look to the EU to
solve these problems no secret to you
that my policy party the center party
goes against a lot of the policies of
the Swedish government but nevertheless
today I feel very proud to be able to
welcome you here wolf christerson here
in democracy's house the European
Parliament
it's with a great deal of Pride that
I've followed the first steps of the
Swedish presidency
the same time there are clouds on the
horizon when it comes to a number of
different policy areas
the first question is climate
we've got the largest climate package in
the eu's history
but these proposals have still not got
through the legislative process and it
seems that governments are
trying to back out of things at home
how can we ensure that we're
climate objectives will apply in 2025
now we are also legislating in the area
of migration we need to ensure that we
have a sustainable and Humane
migration policy will the upcoming
Swedish presidency take responsibility
for migration policy in the future and
are you in a position to do so
and there are also concerns about
democracy in the EU our Union is based
on values if we do not defend them well
what is our identity we'll be in an
identity crisis
the center party is Keen to ensure that
illiberal Governors governments like the
kanchinski government and the Auburn
government change course will the
Swedish presidency defend values
after 30 years in the EU
Sweden is now taking on this huge
responsibility of taking on the
presidency I'd like to wish the
government the best of luck and I hope
that all swedes will ensure that you get
the best and the most out of this
presidency thanks
is Alice kunker for two and a half
minutes
foreign
thank you very much Madam president
Sweden
eu's new presidency state is led by a
puppet government
that in many policy areas is carrying
out the policies of the extreme right
the Swedish presidency
thus raises a major question mark
is it a question of beautiful ideals or
deeds in practice that will Define us as
a union
I'm asking this because Pandora's Box is
wide open and it was our prime minister
who opened Pandora's Box by inviting the
far right to the negotiating table and
it was the liberals who gave him the
keys
Sweden's prime minister is not stupid
he's not been tricked he knows what he's
doing
he thinks it's worth it
right-wing extremism it's just something
he has to accept in order to get power
and he's not alone
unfortunately there's an extreme bright
wave across the EU and it's often
enabled by conservative and liberal
politicians
Heidi fried
Heidi fried is a survivor of the
Holocaust
she reminded me
she reminded many other people as well
of course that
one grain of sand
a lot it falls on top of another and
before you know what you're dealing with
you've got a whole Sand Dune in front of
you
just a few years ago
these kind of things are Unthinkable and
they've become The New Normal
that you say one thing and then do
something else
that you pronounce fine words about the
green transition
and about the rule of law
but you allow climate deniers who see
Victor Auburn as their model well you
allow them to hold the reins
there have to be enough people who dare
to point out each sound grain that falls
we need to ensure that everyone is
included in our society we need protests
to ensure when unscientific decisions
are taken right in the middle of a
climate crisis
common Generations will judge us harshly
they will divide us up into those who
enabled this and those who resisted
thank you
a good floor next to Jean Paul Garo for
two minutes
president
prime minister Sweden is taking the EU
Council presidency for six months at a
time when there are many challenges
firstly in migration where our continent
has become a kind of
uh giant Transit area thanks to the
ideological position of the commission
which
favors high levels of immigration to the
detriment of the nation states the front
takes affair
showed that 300 000 illegal entries had
been detected in the last year an
increase of 64 percent over 2021 the
highest level since 2016. we rely on
Sweden in particular the Democrats
within your majority to put an end to
this crazy migration policy it comes
down to saving our civilization and our
national identities on economics our
protectionist policies smart
protectionism is an Urgent Response to
the unfair protectionism
of the U.S and the IRA and
a plan has been adopted without any
cooperation from a member state that is
also creating unfair uh competition by
the EU
we must build up a common defense and a
European defense policy we regard that
these areas
however must remain the
territory of the member states it's
about sovereignty the EU has practiced a
bellicose stance in the Ukraine conflict
under your presidency prime minister we
should see a return to diplomacy that
would be a significant Advance we can
only encourage you to commit yourself
strongly to that
indispensable route to World Peace
otherwise we risk a war which could
spread at any time the conflict is
leading to a major energy crisis and
exacerbating inflation which is very
hard for families and businesses to bear
in the next six months so if regarding
the eu's fundamental values is going to
be Paramount in Hungary and pole and we
hope that your presidency doesn't play
the commission's game which is
exploiting these values to support its
existing policies
sanctioning and stigmatizing these two
great uh democracies that have always
fought for uh
freedom is scandalous
this must see a return to reason in this
very ideological debate thank you for
one minute
thank you madam president Mr Prime
Minister I would like to congratulate
you for your government it was the
Swedish people want and usually we call
that democracy I thought we needed to
remind that after what we all we heard
this morning
I also want to say that a new year
usually comes with new resolutions and
better decisions but apparently not for
the EU every year we Face the same
problems and every year we make the same
old mistakes the same old mistakes like
moralization taboos political
correctness and inaction of course we
get the same old results that nobody is
waiting for
you know it's like when there is someone
in your life on whom you can never count
despite a thousand promises and excuses
we are that person I cannot blame the
voters who want to break up with us
sometimes as the EU
you would too wouldn't you if you are
always disappointed and let down and
forced to pay taxes for that treatment
so Mr Prime Minister your country has
faced serious crime and the consequences
of failed integration your recent
elections revealed how angry and worried
the Swedish people are I hope this
Swedish presidency will be the
presidency of courage and determination
commitment and achievement the
presidency to tackle child sexual abuse
and online and online protection of our
children to tackle drugs violence and
money laundering to strengthen NATO
together and to address the elephant in
the room illegal migration Mr Prime
Minister you have six months in the
spotlight please show us the courage
for two and a half minutes
[Applause]
Madam president
I well many people who have been looking
forward to the Swedish presidency Sweden
has been known for being at the
Forefront when it comes to climate
policy equality endemic democracy issues
but the right-wing conservative
government that is supported by a
far-right party with wrote The Roots in
neo-nazism
well a lot of uh people like me have
seen their expectations disappointed
the Prime Minister shook hands with the
Holocaust Survivor heady freed and said
that he would never cooperate with the
Sweden Democrats but one year later he's
doing just that
this is a government that has built its
power on a party the Sweden Democrats
who were among Putin's best friends and
orban's Friends
this is a country that is sucking up to
turkey's despot erdogan just to get NATO
membership this is a government that
abolished the Swedish environment
Ministry yes you've heard correctly they
abolished the Swedish environment
department and they reduced the Swedish
climate budget by 58 percent
we should have a minute of Silence
for what the Swedish government has
already managed to destroy besides
simply inviting the far right into power
seems like normal people don't get
anything out from their tax money but at
the same time
we see the issues about our Constitution
and transparency we need to ensure that
we have high ambition when it comes to
the rights of migrants for the climate
and lgbtqi rights
we're worried about an Administration
that becomes more bureaucratic and
administrative
but I don't
feel very certain because I'm worried
that a lot of the people in power are
not Democrats they're racist the Sweden
Democrats
so
I will doing everything possible to hold
the Swedish the presidency accountable
that we do not allow these policies to
break through at the EU level we need a
Humane and solid
migration policy that shows solidarity a
climate policy that can gather better
future to Future generations and we need
to ensure that we can have democracy in
all member states that's something that
I think that we should be looking
forward to there's not one day to lose
in this presidency not one day to to
lose in the battle against Putin and
Orbin hold on sorry
foreign
I'm sorry but there's no interpretation
we
we haven't we have a technical problem
does it work now
sorry Thomas yeah
should work now go ahead
start you can start over
thank you very much microphone
okay
thank you madam president
prime minister
yes
the Swedish presidency is taking action
to preserve European Unity but
preserving
European Unity is
erroneous because there is no such Unity
since the Brussels bureaucracy Brussels
politics has broken down that Unity
brexit is the proof of this namely the
second biggest member State left the EU
that is a result of Brussels politics as
for illegal migrants
the member states
that are in the front line
are basically being left alone
traditional European values
religion family Nation
are now
the targets of Brussels policy the
sovereignty of the member states is to
be undermined and that has destroyed the
unity of the Union our job now is to
restore the unity of the European Union
for that we need a turnaround we need a
different Brussels policy namely
upholding the treaties and we must
respect European diversity for one and a
half minutes
thank you president prime minister
welcome to the European Parliament and
thank you for assuming this important
role of leadership on behalf of all of
the European Union in these important
times let me address two topics firstly
competitiveness the Swedish government
is absolutely right to put in
competitiveness high on the agenda of
the European Union in this first half of
the year because we can only ensure high
standards of living living in Europe we
can only Ensure High social standards if
our economy is competitive if our
economy is strong if we produce Goods
that are demanded on the global markets
to support the competitiveness of our
economy in the conference and the future
of Europe prime minister we have
proposed the introduction of a
competitiveness check at European level
which means that whenever the European
commission will propose legislation in
the future it should make sure that this
improves it strengthens the
competitiveness of our economy it does
not affect it and the Prime Minister my
kind request to you is to make sure that
we work together because this idea was
supported in the conference and the
future of Europe by governments by
commission by citizens by European
Parliament and National Parliament let's
work together for this idea to see the
light of the day second topic the
enlargement of the schengine area
unfortunately under the previous EU
presidency we could not unanimously
agree on the accession of Bulgaria and
Romania to the Schengen area although
these countries fulfill all of the
required conditions as the European
commission has repeatedly said this is
why prime minister let us keep this
topic high on the agenda to make sure we
can fulfill this commitment because as
the accession of Finland and Sweden to
Nato would make us all safer in the
accession of Bulgaria and Romania to the
shanganoia would also make us all safer
thank you very much let's deliver thank
you Siegfried next for one minute
[Applause]
foreign
president Sweden has had an important
and constructive role in previous
presidencies
Swedish foreign policy is well known and
respected
similarly Sweden has always stood up for
democracy human rights and equality
but now questions are being asked about
how the new government will be
performing
will it be different from the approach
taken by previous presidences
prime minister it is very worrying that
your government is dependent upon an
extreme right party for support
in the European Parliament we hope that
Sweden continues to fight with strong
engagement for the rule of law and
democracy
support for Ukraine has to continue
without the shadow of a doubt
strong measures will be required to stop
climate change
reform of the electricity Market
is something that our citizens are
clamoring for
but let's not forget the important work
that Sweden needs to do for a social
Europe
equality and better working conditions
particularly for platform workers are on
the agenda
without a social Europe we have no
Europe at all
next is Karen carlsbro for one and a
half minutes
Madam president Commission
prime minister
well if one thing is taken forgiven it's
European cooperation Europe has
developed from a battle to being one of
the world's best places to live
with freedom and democracy
but this didn't happen all on its own
the EU is the result of compromises and
Democrat Democratic cooperation
it is what it is thanks to will power
and Visions I'm glad that Ulf
christerson has been so clear that
Sweden
as the presidency country will be
working hard for the values that we most
highly value the message to Hungary and
Poland and to all the right-wing
populists in Europe are totally is
totally clear
that has to mean that if you don't
accept the rules of the game there are
consequences
if you turn your back on the eu's values
then you're also saying no to funds
Europe is not a cash point a strong
Democratic EU is required if we are
going to continue to develop the EU
as the world's greatest environmental
organization
that Europe has to take the lead in
climate cooperation you cannot allow
climate denialism to put the brakes on
for EU climate work so I'm very pleased
to see that the presidency wants to do
go to the final straight on the eu's
climate package and bring it home to
Port
the Ukraine is not just fighting for its
own existence but it's fighting for us
we have to continue to give Ukraine our
full support
we're looking forward to a successful a
half year ahead of us thanks
five minutes now
Professor Christensen you take on the
council presidency in a tense time the
EU is seeing me to get through winter
than we all feel uh felt but it's still
not the time to breathe out we need a
council presidency prepared to be
courageous
and to put aside its National positions
we need a council presidency that
clearly can acknowledge EU cooperation
and deliver the goods and to be quite
honest we greens have strong doubts
about whether you'll do that your
alliance which tolerates a far-right EU
opposing part
is destroying a lot of trust in Europe
the good reputation of the Swedish
reputation of the Swedish government in
Europe has been destroyed you need to
show that you are going to live up to
the Democratic traditions of your
predecessors and work and deliver for
Europe as a whole in a crisis we can't
afford a council presidency which is
dependent on the Swedish far right we
need a council presidency which
unambiguously stands behind the EU
position we need a council presidency
that is unambiguously on the side of the
rule of law minorities and strengthening
the EU institutions we need a council
presidency that is also prepared to take
new steps we are happy that you see
competitiveness and Industrial policy as
priorities and we salute North Folk and
other innovative
Swedish cooperate corporations but what
are they calling for active EU
industrial policy and EU fund with
common strategic investments in green
technologies and uh
setups so clear the path for that
otherwise
we'll just see the financing blocked all
the time we need new blueprints on the
table now thank you the sign for two
minutes
thank you madam president uh chair prime
minister of Sweden the transcode
fairness the Swedish presidency during
the first half of this year is going to
be a very important one particularly if
we consider that Sweden has finally got
a decent right-wing government
Sweden is an example
a sad example of the effects of
uncontrolled immigration and how that
could damage the lives of future
Generations our children and
grandchildren and this is an acute
problem across the EU you should always
ask the Sweden democrats for advice on
this issue because they have been
warning of these dangers for many years
that's why I hope that Sweden's
presidency will put greater weight on
the need to control Europe's external
borders prevent illegal immigration and
primarily stand up for security and a
future for Europe's different
nationalities
no less important for this presidency
has to be energy policy the Swedish
government has already shown some
healthy Common Sense by
restarting the promotion of nuclear
power
but common sense is also going to be
needed in during the presidency now we
need the EU to
walk back on its talk of a green
revolutionary Utopia which is not
realistic either economically or even in
uh
preventing climate change
finally I would also like to thank
Sweden for its uh decision to increase
its defense expenditure with again the
context of Russian aggression which is
important for the Sweden itself but also
for northern Europe and Estonia
I'd like to wish you strength and
success and I hope that Sweden
will partially repair some of the damage
that's already been done thank you very
much
um next is Carlo fidanza for one minute
thank you very much Madam president
prime minister commissioner ladies and
gentlemen the new center-right Swedish
government will be at the Helm of the
council at a time that where we are
being rocked by the dramatic
consequences of the war in Ukraine we
have to increase our defense capacity to
fight against external threats so we
have to fight against illegal migration
on the 9th and 10th of February the
various extraordinary Council to start
on this we need
um to send people back and to focus on
migration we also have to make sure we
have Innovative tools for our businesses
and not all damaging recipes for the
internal market we've got to make sure
we have security of energy Supply and
the same when it comes to Commodities
and raw materials we have to make sure
that the green transition is more
sustainable from economic and social
point of view we have to be very
concrete and I think it can be done the
best of success Nikolai Willem sen for
one minute
prime minister
the Swedish EU presidency has many
challenges War energy crisis climber
battle and a grotesquely growing
economic inequality also here in Europe
these are all important areas but today
I would like to focus on something which
is too often overlooked that is working
conditions for most people
your presidency will be negotiating
about both the platform directive and
about the eu's new rules for asbestos
in both cases it's important that
protection of workers is Central we must
protect the rights of platform workers
we should not protect the profits of the
great platform giant and we should also
protect millions of EU citizens lives
and health from the deadly asbestos
I hope Sweden will contribute to that
don't just look at profits in the short
term that will cost us much more in the
long term
wolf christerson it's time to start
working for most people
is Nicola bear for one minute
prime minister the right is back in
power in Sweden and Europeans already
reaping the benefits Stockholm made it
clear very quickly its EU presidency
would not be the presidency of Migrant
redistribution after Decades of openness
and unlimited reception with one-fifth
of the population having been born
abroad it is very clear there's been a
huge increase in the number of homicides
or rapes thefts and police stations
being attacked with hand grenades Mass
migration even in a country which is the
most generous in the world is a
resounding failure that has turned some
cities of these Scandinavian Paradise
into Afghan suburbs
we have to make sure that we don't have
more migrants arriving here some ideas
to develop during your presidency prime
minister instead of receiving illegal
migrants expelling them instead of
disarming frontex giving them the right
means to protect our borders instead of
uploading the ngos that are complicit in
human trafficking pointing the finger at
them and sanctioning them Stockholm has
returned to its senses let's hope that
Brussels follows its examples
thank you madam president prime minister
welcome to Strasbourg the Swedish
presidency is opening as you recalled at
a time of major crisis and I'd like to
thank you because in this context you
are through your government
demonstrating it's possible to repair
Europe you say you want a Greener uh
safer more free Europe Greener not
against science but as you do basing
yourself on the best of European
intelligence in particular the nuclear
industry which will help us get uh
Beyond carbon more safely and of course
we haven't been able to stop things
entering Europe but we've tried to
control the border and you talk about a
safer Europe and spending more money he
doesn't necessarily make a
society's more prosperous we're trying
to allow freedom and leaving member
states their role in responsibility
prime minister we Face existential
challenges
in the wonderful journey of Nils elders
and Malouf said that intelligence makes
us Stand Out amongst princes but I think
you will demonstrate that intelligence
and that wisdom you can rely on your
political family the Epp for supporting
you in that route despite all the
adversity and despite
the denials of the reality that continue
to prosper in the EU institutions we
need a strong Swedish presidency to
repair Europe and strengthen it in the
Dreadful International context we are
familiar with today prime minister good
luck
[Applause]
Brando benefit one minute
thank you president metzoda
prime minister
Sweden takes up the Baton at a crucial
historical moment we have to make sure
that we work towards a Greener Europe
that will be a Trailblazer when it comes
to climate neutrality up to 2050
reducing net emissions by at least 55
percent by 2030 that has not stop and
let us not go backwards we need those
who are dealing with migration to stick
together you cannot look the other way
you cannot postpone the work on the
migration pack to 2024 this is
unacceptable we cannot be held hostage
by vetoes and a certain approach by
throwing a spanner in the works and not
coming up with a joint solution now
artificial intelligence is also very
important I'm eagerly awaiting
negotiations together with Mr tudorache
the co-repator but we I would like to
tell you that European Parliament is
going to stand firm and make sure that
we we don't have mass biometric
surveillance of people and the lowering
of Standards we need a more united and
stronger Europe closer to its citizens
thank you Mr Dante one minute
yeah thank you very much Madam president
prime minister colleagues
the Swedish presidency is going to be
decisive in completing quite a number of
key files for this legislative term as
we which we're now moving into the end
phase of I'm thinking of all the
measures on Energy Efficiency and
Renewables these are important
instruments for freeing ourselves from
dependence on Russian gas
and for solving an energy crisis and I'm
glad to see that the presidency wants a
high level of ambition
I'm also pleased to see that their
attention is being paid to trade
particularly important at the Historical
moment we face
only by diversifying our energy sources
not giving in to the temptation to close
ourselves to the world that's the only
way we can bring together sovereignty
and freedom
and try and solve some of the issues
that have been afflicting Us in recent
months
but it's not all good news
there's still some amazement about some
statements from the Swedish government
which has been using sovereignist
language
when it comes to finding a solution to
the migration issues this is a
short-sighted approach a common
management of flows is the only solution
and that is a decisive issue for the
future of our Union thank you take a
stroke for one and a half minutes
the president Council presidency Mr
Cruces and Commissioners the pector
migration and Asylum has entered the
crucial stage the council reached
agreements on border control and
security pretty rapidly but it stores on
the question how to share responsibility
the fact is not a pick and choose game
it is a package to ensure all elements
protection standards equal division of
responsibility and security measures and
it's upon the Swedish presidency to
complete this whole package in time
and the success of the pact hangs upon a
strong and effective solidarity
mechanism based on common responsibility
this is the key to ending pushback
practices and lives lost at sea and the
key to ensuring proper Asylum procedures
and it's the key we expect you to use to
end the deadlock and give me one hint
the first entry rule in the current
doubling regulation is not fair for the
Border countries but it does not work in
practice either
but taking common responsibility which I
think we should do does not mean a
common effort to shift it to third
countries
this is what happens with prioritizing
migration in all EU foreign policies
development Aid aims at reducing poverty
and not that returning migrants
the idea to refuse tariff preferences to
the least developed countries if they
don't cooperate is a new law in this
tendency of migration deals
I wish the Swedish government a
successful presidency with the right
sense of responsibility inside and
outside the EU and a sound moral compass
thank you
thank you Danica I don't see it over
hakarine and so we'll go straight to
Bogdan ronsa one minute
thank you
um
so
probably is
so we have right-wing parliaments we
have right-wing voters that's why there
are right-wing governments who will
bring back uh competitiveness and uh
order in our European union and we're
very pleased that the Swedish prime
minister has a set up some very
reasonable priorities which we accept
and we support we're pleased that
everyone is in favor of energy
Independence and nuclear energy in
particular because that will ensure
stability in the European Union we of
course have to think about refugees and
we have to reduce illegal immigration to
the European Union because the illegal
immigration causes a lot of problems for
us within the union we have to do away
with the corruption starting with
European Parliament I mean the European
Parliament is criticized Poland for not
respecting Law and Order what about Law
and Order in this house and we also need
to be economically competitive and not
ideologically opposed to Asia in the
United States just because we don't like
them thank you so it is next for one and
a half minutes
commissioner Prime Minister President
I'm very much looking forward to the
Swedish presidency because I'm sure that
two areas that are close to my heart
will be dealt with first of all
competitiveness of the European economy
and secondly concrete measures for
solving the migration crisis first of
all
I think everyone in this Parliament is
interested in what our companies need to
be successful Innovative and competitive
ultimately it's only our entrepreneurs
that create jobs
at the moment
there's aggressive competition for uh
where to locate Investments and that's
why it's important that we provide
support to our companies but
nevertheless we need to deal with the
subject of excess bureaucracy
because this is leading to more
relocations outside Europe
and we need the sorry the measures that
we have been taking in recent years have
led to more bureaucracy for
entrepreneurs rather than less
Swedish members in Epp are doing an
excellent job and I hope that you will
uh help us to fight against the
bureaucratic monster secondly on the
subject of migration at the European
Union once again is facing a migration
crisis
in my region of Austria we are some of
the most affected regions
and we are taking on
the more refugees than pretty much any
country in Europe
the council and the Parliament have
already committed themselves to
implementing the objectives of the
Asylum migration pact and with your
Swedish experience I'm sure that we'll
find a good solution best of luck for
one minute
gracias president thank you very much
Madam president vice president
prime minister
of course your presidency has to
continue fleshing out the policies
linked to the priorities of our
societies the fight against inflation
and climate change but today I'd like to
talk about an outstanding issue if we
don't tackle a layer there will be
medium term and long-term problems and
that's migration policy especially
legal migration paths all the studies
show that we need more
manpower in the EU and we have moved
towards a health union and an energy
Union let's do the same when it comes to
Common migration policy that is why we
have to give the green light to the
migration and Asylum pact now and that
is why we also have to develop legal
migrational paths especially when it
comes to the single permit and a
long-term workers we've we're working
very hard and quickly here in the
European Parliament to achieve a of that
and we count on the Swedish presidency
to help reach a consensus in the council
and the commission president vice
president prime minister I hope you have
a safe secure healthy and sustainable
year thank you next is
for one minute
thank you madam president
dear prime minister
many priorities Ukraine energy migration
economy
many important debates and decisions to
come I'm confident
you will fulfill your objectives and
together with many of my colleagues you
have our support for doing that but I
wish to put on a political radar just
like my colleague did a few minutes ago
the issue of Schengen for Romania and
Bulgaria because whatever
happened at the GHA Council in December
he rose the very logic of how the
council works we had over years many
examples of member states
abusing unanimity playing their vetoes
for political gain but at the end of the
day there was always a trade-off that
allowed the majority to Prevail with
allowed reason to Prevail in December we
didn't have that
we had a member say that simply said no
that accepted no evidence no facts no
arguments that ignored all efforts by
the presidency
by the commission by fellow member
states to find Solutions in fact it
wanted no solution
and such unwillingness to compromise the
president that he rose the council's
cohesion and pushes European citizens to
lose faith in how Europe serves them you
must now work to reverse this President
and sooner you do this the better
this Parliament has been a consistent
advocate for complete exchange
integration we can count on our support
in the months to come thank you thank
you so much Drago's next is kirenka for
one minute
president prime minister to deal with
the cost of living crisis in exacerbated
by the energy crisis and with the
climate crisis we have a simple solution
which is to insulate homes as rapporteur
for the revision of the energy
performance building in buildings uh
report I would like the EU and the
member states to tackle this
crisis so simultaneously they're
responsible for a third of greenhouse
gas emissions in the EU
restructuring plan at a European level
would
create hundreds of thousands of jobs
locally and would contribute to tackling
these two crises with ambitious minimum
standards for energy performance
we could put behind us energy poverty
that is crippling many millions of
Europeans and this would be a social
Safeguard and protect those at most at
risk I do
hope that there will be productive
negotiations with the Swedish presidency
thank you
uh next is Harold vilimski for one and a
half minutes
thank you very much Madam president
ladies and gentlemen first of all I'd
like to express my pleasure
that in Sweden we have
a government in control that is turned
away from this leftist path
that has brought Sweden into so much
trouble in recent years
and now we have Sweden as a council
presidency and I think that we're in
good hands I've known the Sweden
democrats for many years they're a party
that does good Fair politics for their
own country
and they
are also responding to a large
part of public opinion in Europe I could
mention uh Hungary
where
Victor orbit is one Fair elections in
Italy we've got uh Maloney and salvidian
Power
that's the situation in Poland
and I could also mention my the
situation in my own country in Austria
where we are pursuing policies that are
now breaking through and that are
creating positive momentum that really
support diversity on our continents
so that
cultures can come together in friendship
we should be turning away instead from a
policy of mass migration
abuse of our social welfare systems
abuse of our Asylum systems let's hope
that we can push Europe into a better
future the diversity of cultures is the
precondition for ensuring
that our continent will be prosperous
and do well
so that we as an EU can do well so we
don't end up with some mishmash
situation where all cultures end up
losing at the end of the day and people
turn away from Europe thank you very
much Ralston for one minute
premiere
thank you very much Madam president
prime minister
one of your priorities is to reach an
agreement with the ACP countries
more and more ACP representatives are
worried about the agreement in question
especially when it comes to sexual and
reproductive Health rights Provisions
because they see it as an obligation to
legalize abortion many of these ACP
countries give great importance a touch
great importance to the protection of
life before birth
so the I urge you in a very simple way
do not impose this populist
[Music]
um
these morals on others and stopping life
before it comes to life because uh life
is a gift from God
so I appeal to you for your support
and of course the is the issue of
freedom of religion and belief in order
to
get enough stuff I think this is crucial
we need to make sure that we have a
considerable budget thank you
thank you very much Madam president
commissioner
prime minister colleagues
prime minister You Can Count upon the
European Parliament
Inc giving concrete form to the
objectives that you've set
to say
a more a safer
Freer more competitive Europe that
defends European values at the same time
we hope that we can also count upon the
council in achieving these objectives
it's not enough just to discuss and
analyze
who need to bring these files through to
a conclusion
we need strategic autonomy but for that
we need projects
and we need to ensure they don't have an
excessively high cost per hour citizens
how much are we paying for the fact
that we do not have secure supply for
energy we need an energy Union a digital
union we need uh civil protection we
need safe connectivity we have needed EU
security and defense and to for all of
that we need resources we need financial
resources
now we are happy to review the
multi-annual financial framework in
order to harness it for these common
objectives the council says it's
available
for reviewing the mff
that's an important point to bear in
mind
so what we need is new Revenue we need
to show solidarity with future
Generations
and we need to look at the cost of Next
Generation EU and the the debt that's
been taken out for the national
resilience plans
we need a robust budget for a strong
European Union
and there's another point we shouldn't
forget
and that's our relationship with those
who also defend European values
that's why it's important
that our foreign relations are based
upon our values that helps us to ensure
our own sovereignty and that's why
mercasol
has to be taken out of the draw and
pushed through to a conclusion a minute
thank you very much
through tall man
Madame President members prime minister
well I'm proud and happy that the
Swedish presidency
was initiated in my own home region
Northern Sweden this region has a lot of
the technology and development that we
need for the green transition fossil
free steel battery factories new battery
technologies and green energy
but if we're going to achieve our full
potential we need to build a society to
go with it
and we need all levels of society to be
with us we need better functioning
infrastructure we need Education and
Training skills we need roads and
railways
local authorities authorities need to
get more support
across the EU and it's not just me and
the opposition who are saying these
things
the state needs to deliver
and the state needs to deliver across a
whole range of areas
in on Swedish radio I heard uh
businessman talking about the investment
that the Prime Minister was pushing with
the uh Volvo and northvolt but he said
will there be enough wind power
in 15 years time we might have a new
nuclear power online but then it will be
too late
so my hope is that the Swedish
presidency will clear up all the
concerns around the green transition and
energy
and being building Sweden that is
cohesive and
developing the whole of the EU in a
cohesive manner small countries
can use fine words we've heard plenty of
those
but we don't need just fine words
that's not what creates influence in
changing the situation now we have to
act as a model that is one way to have
influence thank you very much and good
luck Sweden I've been cleaner for one
minute
[Applause]
foreign
Minister for European Affairs vice
president Chef chovich the six months of
the Swedish presidency will be decisive
in terms of a major reform expected for
a long time but held in deadlock for a
long time which is the European policy
on Asylum and migration which was
presented in September 2020 this Asylum
and migration pact is finally making
progress in particular
thanks to establishing a joint road map
between Parliament and Council as
requested by my group renew Europe
we want that report that reform adopted
by April 2024 the war in Ukraine and
numerous crises around us show how much
a migration Asylum reform is necessary
how much we need to be able to take in
those who are persecuted and to fight
against human trafficking in solidarity
and responsibility
prime minister are you prepared to make
progress with all pro-european Centrist
forces on this European pact on Asylum
and migration thank you
for one minute
dear prime minister Madam president of
the ambitious
intentions of the presidency are very
important because we're confronting a
very difficult year it will be more
difficult than the one that has just
ended War has not come to an end we must
have remain unified in our support for
Ukraine financially economically and
militarily but also for the refugees for
those countries that have received
Ukrainian refugees including Poland to
have to be supported
Poland has not received a single Euro
from Brussels to help with lots of
immoral support but no financial support
and we are supporting millions of
refugees so it's a difficult year the
fit for 55 package is still being
worked on but not really moving forward
and that was something that we started
working on even before the war broke out
at the same time there is this a frozen
directive which will have to be verified
by the presidency
concerning a taxation of coal and Gas
Energy where there are huge increases in
prices and profits for the Distributors
and then there are the corruption
scandals in the European Parliament at
the European Parliament has been hugely
weakened and I'm very surprised by the
leader of the socialistic group who
really should bring her own house in
order before moralizing thank you
prime minister as the representative of
the Czech Republic in the European
Parliament I welcome that you have uh
supported many priorities that were
launched by the Czech residency the
Ukraine as you said in Ukraine they
fight for our values for our way of life
so you you together with all the members
of the EU wish to support the Ukraine in
military
humanitarian terms are you going to
support a new sanction package which is
responding to further Russian attacks
against civilians we also have to deal
with impact of the Russian aggression on
our economies and citizens we the
parliament is going to talk about
inflation food prices food security
should be continue to be the center of
our attention and the Swedish presidency
should continue along this path it
should ensure food security and support
for European Farmers we are awaiting new
legislation new G
um old Technologies
proposals that are to be presented in
this period I wish the Swedish
presidency accelerate works on the new
tribunal to deal with aggression
committed by putting its government and
Russia I hope the Swedish presidency
will make sure this tribunal is
established I wish the Swedish
presidency is active in stopping a
forceful deportation by Ukraine of
Ukraine citizens children in particular
and their adoption by the Russians this
is a genocide and against the Ukrainian
nation and crime against children and
their rights I wish you a lot of
strength a lot of energy in order to
maintain European unity in all these
areas for one minute
thank you very much
president vice president
prime minister I'd like to
wish you the best of success I'm sure
that the Swedish presidency of the
council will be a great success there's
a major priority Romanian access to the
Schengen your known uh as being a
correct and Democratic Society in Sweden
and we hope that you'll be the champion
of putting right this great wrong done
against Romania because despite European
regulations and in spite of all the
checks carried out by the European
commission Romania and the Romanians
were refused a fundamental right that is
being full citizens of the European
Union
prime minister
when it comes to prices when it comes to
inflations when it comes to the 3
million Ukrainian refugees passing
through Romania
I think they should
be some acknowledgment paid to that
there's a lot of goods uh traffic also
coming through Romania so please put
right this wrong the
signs are good I think this is the right
time for you to put right or wrong which
is obvious and has been done against
Romania and
the Romanians please uh work towards a
Romanian accession to the Schengen area
thank you prime minister for one minute
thank you president
Mr Prime Minister
Commissioner of dear colleagues we wish
success to the Swedish presidency he
brought up a lot of important topics
that you're going to work on we need to
be United
supporting Ukraine we need to work on
energy we need to work on a lot of
geopolitical subjects there are two
subjects that have not been mentioned by
you uh one of them is the future of the
shingen area Bulgarian Romania need to
become full-fledged members of it why
isn't this one of your subjects how are
we going to win the hearts of European
citizens how are we going to in make
sure that in
2024 everybody strives for for an
ambitious European project
if Bulgaria and Romania and yet still
waiting and another important topic the
Western Balkans are you going to
continue the policies of the previous
presidents is they really focused on the
western Balkans but you haven't included
this topic in your priorities is there
going to be a summit with the countries
from the West Balkans it's a very
important geopolitical issues no matter
who the president who holds the
presidency
110
510 there you go thank you
thank you very much for giving me the
floor Madam president
the Swedish presidency is coming at just
the right moment
people across Europe are concerned we've
got a number of crises ahead of us
you've got energy crisis the war in uh
between Europe and Ukraine inflation but
particularly uh fuel prices are high for
normal people
innovation has been very important for
Sweden and it will be important for the
future we are a model for other
countries and we should be but the
Swedish government is showing how
important it is to have good cooperation
cooperation between different groups and
different political orientations
that allows inclusion of people with
different uh political opinions
so Sweden's government should be a model
for all of us in this house we all have
been elected democratically to this
house but many people in this house have
an odd view of democracy
their political ideas seem to be just uh
throwing stones at others
I hope that all christerson's government
will be successful and have the best of
luck in the presidency thanks thank you
Peter Sean Kelly's next for one and a
half minutes
foreign
Sweden takes on the presidency of the
council at a time of great flocks for
the EU as we Face numerous political
economic and security challenges
almost one year ago Putin's tanks rolled
into Ukraine and began his bloody war of
aggression
the warden Ukraine exposed
vulnerabilities in our critical systems
and triggered an unprecedented energy
crisis inside the block
we must future proof our Energy System
I call on the Swedish government during
his presidency of the council to draw on
Sweden's long-standing reputation as a
climate leader and to bring forward
measures that allow for the efficient
production storage and distribution of
energy to Citizens and businesses across
Europe
Guided by the Energy Efficiency first
principle
in particular I sincerely hope that
during the Swedish presidency the
Parliament and the council can work
closely to secure an agreement on the
energy performance of buildings
directive of which I am the lead
negotiator on behalf of the Epp group
this file is particularly unique and
addresses a fundamental pillar of
achieving our climate goals the built
environment
difficult decisions will have to be made
but as legislators it is our
responsibility to look at our long-term
interests regardless of political gain
this information about eppd is already
starting to circulate and the EU
institutions and member state
governments must take action to set the
record straight it is my hope that the
Swedish presidency can be a leader in
this area and I look forward to close
cooperation over the next six months to
deliver a strong and effective eppd
comma Groupon
thank you Sean Margarita Marcus for one
minute
thank you very much Madam president
prime minister
vice president chefkovic
the revision of the rules for economic
governance of the EU and the debate on
new owned resources to finance the
challenges we face at the European level
these are two of the most important
points on the European agenda of this
semester
when it comes to economic governance we
need the presidency to get an agreement
in the council
so that the legislative proposals
actually get through and the Parliament
is in a position to play its role as
co-legis later the member states need
clear simple transparent balanced timely
rules so that they can prepare their
National budgets for 2024.
we need to know what the intentions of
the EU institutions are when it comes to
activating or disactivating the Escape
clause and when it comes to new own
resources
that is going to be essential for
meeting the commitments we've taken
under Next Generation EU but also for
raising the level ambition of the EU
it's not enough to talk about strategic
autonomy we need to build it and finance
it so on these two issues we hope that
the Swedish presidency feels the urgency
thanks thank you very much Margarita nil
store Wells is next for one minute
foreign
thank you madam president put on your
seat belts and your headphones because
I'm going to speak in Swedish that
doesn't concern you probably
uh what is
well what can Sweden do as a presidency
what can they do better
there's an unfortunate tendency in the
European Union to describe everything in
these wonderful terms everything is
fantastic and money's flowing in etc etc
but more realism could create more Trust
we might need a bit of that
in the legal debate on the EU
there's a term that recurs
competence creep
well what does that actually mean it
means that the border between what the
union should be doing and what others
should be doing is a little bit of a
gray area
and that gives space for a number of
populist movements well I'm sure you
know them very well we certainly know
them in Finland
and then pretty much all European
countries
the legislative
process starts with Council conclusions
but if you look at the situation a
little bit more closely the situation is
a bit problematic these are very roughly
written they're very vague they don't
steer the process the way that would
better reflect their member states
interests and intentions
once said
have you lost your words and your papers
if I use that as a moment
to think twice
to think whether what you had written
was any good and in most cases Council
conclusions are very badly written
there was a good reference in your
speech that I was very grateful for
you said I woke up in Helsinki I was
very pleased with that thanks a lot
Darkness the next is Benoit gang puran
minute and parole
is
prime minister
you talked about supporting Ukraine
economically and militarily and you've
made that an absolute priority of your
presidency which is something I welcome
you've seen
during recent days however the
hesitation that various European
countries have shown when it comes to
providing military support and I hope
prime minister that you'll use your
presidency
to boost
European Defense which I think is
essential for our sovereignty and
Independence and will show the strength
of Europe now this sovereignty also
relates to strategic sectors such as
digital
energy Health defense which I've already
mentioned Etc
and for us this sovereignty really shows
our independence and strength it shows
it to our citizens but also to the rest
of the world
and I hope prime minister you will move
in this direction during your presidency
to ensure that our independence is
stronger so that we can defend our
Democratic Values which are crucial for
the rest of the world and for Europeans
thank you it's bigger simplest time for
one minute
here and then
thank you
digitalization artificial intelligence
drivers for more Innovation and
opportunity in Europe
we need to look at digital fundamental
rights from the outset however
looking at the work program for the
Swedish presidency
what I see is that the digital agenda is
not all that prominent the E privacy
regulation is only mentioned in passing
it is high time that e-privacy becomes a
top priority we need an agreement here
so that we know that we can rely on our
Communications being confidential we
need legal certainty for companies in
Europe
and what about people they want to be
able to communicate without fearing that
they will be profiled when they browse
on the Internet or that their
Communications will be leaked so
recognize the protection of digital
fundamental rights finally once and for
all reach an agreement on the e-privacy
regulation or directive thank you thank
you very good next is ever popular for
one minute
foreign
thank you madam president uh dear prime
minister thank you for coming
um vice president I would like to
congratulate you
um Mr Prime Minister
um that anti-money laundering is also
one of your priorities under your
presidency it is definitely also a
priority for this house much more so
after qatargate and the realization that
this Parliament is not immune to
corruption
they use hands-off approach towards
dirty money has only yelled its scandals
the time has come to crack down on it
the year must be bolder than ever if it
wants to put an end to its complicity
towards illicit Finance
it needs a new anti-money laundering
Authority
to put an end to economic nationalism to
make sure Russian oligarchs pay for
their complicity in the crimes that are
being committed in Ukraine
this new Authority will be a game
changer an eu-wide supervisor able to
utilize Financial intelligence too
thanks to it you will no longer be
laundromat for tax evaders and other
criminals I look very much forward to
working with you with the Swedish
presidency to make this Vision a reality
let's get it done
thank you very much
Eva Andrews next for one minute go ahead
Andres
dear prime minister dear Swedish
colleagues
first of all I would like to
congratulate into thanks Swedish prime
minister for such a clear statement on
Ukraine on Ukraine being major strategic
priority for Swedish presidents and I
would like to stress importance of just
few points of this broad Ukraine agenda
it would be very important that during
Swedish presidency decisions should be
made in order to start EU membership
negotiations with Ukraine and Moldova
during this year we need to win not only
military battles but also political and
geopolitical battles against Kremlin
second as it was mentioned by my
colleagues during this week European
Parliament I hope will pass a resolution
on the establishment of special Tribunal
for the crime of vagration I hope that
Swedish presidency together with
Ukrainian authorities will do everything
distributional to be established during
this year and the last point after
Kremlin
once more terrorist attack against
apartment buildings this time in nipro I
hope that Swedish presidency will put
Wagner and other Russian military groups
on to EU list of terrorist organizations
as European Parliament recently demanded
good luck look at you
thank you very much Andrew's next
ethereuten for one
president presidency Commission
security
effective management operational and
strategic cooperation
do not be misguided these words are not
about enhanced cooperation on defense
these come from the Swedish presidency
intentions on Asylum and migration pact
and I'm aware of the political
background of the Swedish government
that I did not expect many nice words
nevertheless I think it's important to
emphasize that we are always talking
about people people like all of us here
dehumanizing them leads to crowded
refugee camps pushbacks even shooting at
our borders dehumanizing them leads to
unfounded fears in our society instead
of solidarity we need and only by
including humanity and solidarity in our
European Asylum and migration policy we
can come out better and stronger
together and I noticed that the rule of
law and fundamental rights are
priorities of the presidency and I
applaud that but I will ask you be
consistent and make these values also
Central in all your work not only when
electorally convenient having said this
I wish you all the best and look forward
to for cooperation thank you
thank you size Nexus dachancholos for
one minute
prime minister
I come from Romania and it will be no
surprise to you that I will talk about
my country for me and millions of
Romanians and bulgarians blocking our
legitimate access to Schengen was a huge
disappointment at the end of last year
this can have incalculable consequences
if this is not actively addressed in
coming months
I would ask your presidency to correct
this Injustice through diplomacy through
proactive mediation in order to overcome
these blockages especially when it comes
to Austria and the Netherlands unless
this has done any discussion about
European solidarity
will be viewed with mistrust
by citizens who believe in the
solidarity and have a strong attachment
to European values
discussions for an agreement on Asylum
and migration must not block the
legitimate and legal right of Romanian
and bulgarians it tends to be part of
the Schengen area with political will
all the prerequisites are in place for a
decision on access and to shengen by the
end of his presidency thank you uh
dachan next is Carlo wrestler for one
minute
thank you very much Madam chair Mr Prime
Minister dear colleagues
in the new era of deep uncertainty in
Europe
as the best place to live in the whole
world
if it wishes to retain this title needs
to seriously think about investing and
its security including the state border
security
and the economic and technological
competitiveness your presidency can
direct Europe in a good direction
therefore I salute your focus to the
issue of Defense migrations
energy
all of these topics that have a critical
influence to everybody's life and are a
true test of European policies and the
European civilization do not neglect
work in our immediate neighborhood
Bosnian herzegov and other countries in
southeast of Europe because this is the
key it is important and it is something
that concerns all of us the Czech
presidency Croatia will remember as a
very quality good and quality time and I
wish all the success to Sweden in
difficult times let us get back to our
Basics to Our Roots Common Sense
policies are something that made Sweden
and Europe what it is today and they
will preserve Europe in the future thank
you but Carlo I give the floor next to
lukash kohout for one minute
thank you
well the Swedish presidency is now
taking over the Helm of the European
Union and I'm very pleased
because Sweden is a country that
takes up challenges and acts for example
you've joined NATO and in Europe we need
Brave leadership during these difficult
times we need a consensus to build
European security and defense policy we
need to help Ukraine as well Ukraine is
fighting for European values for all of
us
but we also need leadership that is not
afraid to take on
important social issues I'm the
co-rapporter on the Istanbul convention
rapporteur and I'm also a
feminist and I'm
fully convinced that adopting this
legislation is a priority for you and
that's a good thing the work that I'm
doing with Mr kokolari who's Swedish
will help in many cases where there's
violence and I hope that the Parliament
and Council will open a new chapter in
the rights of women in Europe and the
convention on right the violence against
women will be ratified by the Hawaii
thank you environment for one and a half
minutes
foreign
minister commissionerskovic
as a Swede and as a member of the
moderate poety I look forward to this
Swedish presidency
optimistically Swedish Sweden is taking
on the leadership at a time when Europe
is being pressed from several fronts in
parallel crises with current war on our
continent
urgent climate challenges
electricity prices and inflation sending
shock waves through the economy and
European businesses facing ever stiffer
Global competition
let me focus on competitiveness
Europe is falling behind there not just
now faced with this urgent situation
this has been ongoing for some time
we have failed in nurturing a business
climate
our red tape is too heavy our taxes are
too high we must be very clear when we
talk about this
and
these realizations must urge us to act
it is urgent that we improve our
business climate if we want to
strengthen our economic standing
globally
that is why I want to applaud our prime
minister
because he so clearly has said that he
will place competitiveness at the center
of his presidency
in these difficult times we cannot
afford to continue as if nothing were
happening
incentives to entrepreneurship need to
be strengthened we need to adopt free
trade agreements we need to do away with
red tape
we need to intensify digitalization and
we need to increase our investments in
research and development we must try
every Avenue to improving our business
climate because it is only by having
vital and profitable companies that we
can regain the path to growth and a
stable economic framework
a sound business climate is the key to
continued wealth for European citizens
I want to wish our prime minister all
the very best as well as to the our
Minister for European Affairs and to the
Swedish government thank you next for
one minute
foreign
Madam president commissioner
prime minister Ulf Christian
in times
when worry is present in every cell of
our
beings I'm reminded of the words of our
previous prime minister Olaf the society
has been made by humans and if something
is wrong in it we can change it
colleagues every week at least 50 women
are murdered in the EU let that sink in
not one word was said about this heinous
crime in Prime the prime minister's
speech
as the lead negotiator on the directive
on men's violence against women and
domestic violence my message my question
would be whether the Swedish presidency
will work actively so that I and my
colleague Francis Fitzgerald's proposal
will be adopted to adopt Swedish
legislation more broadly on on purchase
of sexual act
we're shocked by the tone deafness in
abolishing Swedish feminist foreign
policy and in cuts to Global development
Aid that is has no place in a time of
global challenges girls in Afghanistan
Iran and other countries around the
world are fighting for their lives and
their freedom
we're told that they want to prioritize
a safer world but how are we
contributing to that when we remain
silent in the face of the Iranian regime
when we will not declare the despotism
that is happening in Turkey having said
all this I want to wish our prime
minister and the Swedish presidency all
the best in their work thank you thank
you very much we have a number of
colleagues who have asked for catch the
eye which means that five colleagues
will be given the flow from their seat
we start with
and then arba kokalari
thank you
I would like to wish you every success
throughout your presidency you have
selected wonderful priorities security
rule of law
the digital and green transition I'm
particularly pleased that you have made
competitiveness one of your Flagship
initiatives it is vital that the
European Union continues to flourish
that our companies continue to flourish
and create jobs they need qualified
Workforce and we need legislation that
Fosters investment in Europe
I am pleased to see that you are
striving for better legislation you will
organize a conference next week in
Stockholm on this topic you will drive
forward any initiatives that will help
to make Europe more competitive
the commission will carry out an
assessment
of the impact that all legislative
proposals have on competitiveness it is
wonderful that the council will also
make this a priority we in Parliament
hold this very daily competitiveness in
Europe is very important to us next is
thank you madam president Roberto
maxillon prime minister Sweden notices
and colleagues I noted here that the
Swedish social Democrats and the
environment the green party have not
quite recovered from their electoral
defeat in Sweden
well they've closed their eyes to high
crime levels and All That Remains for
them is
scare tactics
and dirt slinging
we Face the greatest security threat in
Europe where Russia's war on Ukraine
this is the greatest threat we've faced
since World War II we see skyrocketing
costs for households and a serious
energy and climate crisis all of this
requires a strong EU that can act and a
United Europe colleagues it was the
moderate party that brought Sweden into
the EU the moderate party is the party
that has encouraged Swedish NATO
membership I am convinced that we need
Swedish moderate leadership and that we
need a party that is friendly to Europe
more than ever good luck with
christerson Europe is counting on
Swedish leadership and your government's
leadership
Juan Fernando go ahead
president met solo prime minister the
Swedish
presidency
will be decisive in 2023
in order for us to achieve what we
wanted to during this parliamentary term
there are expectations but also concerns
which have been mentioned I mean there's
been something that's been alluded to as
the threat of mass migration and that
goes against what the majority of this
Parliament agreed with the road map
signed together with the commission and
Council including Sweden
the new migration and Asylum pact is a
historic opportunity to provide a
response to
the issue of migration in line with our
European values I mean it's the only way
that can genuinely be effective and what
we need is a balance we need
a balance between binding solidarity and
shared responsibility
we shouldn't simply turn our backs on
those States who are on the front line
in the Mediterranean or also those which
have a border in the Atlantic which is
the case of Spain and the Canary Islands
thank you president
College
thank you president prime minister
honorable members I too would like to
wish the Swedish presidency every best
and hope for better results you say you
want a more ethical fairer Europe a
Greener safer Europe
I didn't hear enough reference to social
justice
yesterday we commemorated the 30th
anniversary of the single Market but we
don't really have a truly single Market
prime minister you have an opportunity
to go down in the annals of History by
making sure that we have a truly unified
single Market ensuring that all citizens
including citizens of my country and
Bulgaria enjoy full uh freedom of
movement when it comes to Goods do you
think that drivers spending two three
days waiting at Borders to transport
goods are really benefiting from the
single Market what about this idea can
you ensure true freedom of movement I
hope that we can expect solidarity from
you
commercial
president prime minister
now we talk about trade we've heard you
say that trade is one of the priorities
of your presidencies and that that has
been the case because in previous
presidencies and semesters trade has
apparently not been a priority for the
different presidencies however I have to
say with some concern
that I don't agree with that reading I
hope that this was the case because they
had very busy agendas and limited time
of course trade is key to Prosperity
Europe needs trade
we especially everyone key agreement
the mercosaur agreement which we hope
that you will unblock Europe its
companies its jobs and its competitive
need trade agreements and the Microsoft
agreement is key and therefore I would
ask for your action and courage
when time comes for your presidency to
play a key role we hope that 2023 will
be the year when we have trade
agreements with all of Latin America and
that the Microsoft agreement stops being
a problem and becomes a solution to the
challenges that European citizens face
thank you to conclude the debate I give
the flow back to vice president
before giving it to the prime minister
to conclude
my rush you have the floor
thank you very much Madam president the
Prime Minister honorable members of the
European Parliament first and foremost I
would like to thank you all for debate
which highlighted major challenges we
have to tackle and face together
first and foremost support for Ukraine
we will be working together on
continuous financial support and as you
are probably informed first disbursement
of 3 billion euros to our Ukraine and
France was just made this morning
I'm sure that the Swedish presidency
enclosed cooperation with the commission
and the European Parliament will explore
all other possibilities how to assist
the brave ukrainians to defend their
country from military aid through
support for Ukrainian strategic
infrastructure down to reconstruction
and preparation for Ukraine's
integration into the European Union
second Hill challenge which was rightly
highlighted by many honorable members is
competitiveness we very much appreciate
the fact that the Swedish presidency put
this so high on the agenda
for this semester competitive Europe
means economically and politically
strong Europe
strong Europe which is able to play its
role as a global actor to help others to
defend the weaker but also to guarantee
strong social policies Europe is so
known for
in our visit to kirona we heard from
companies like norwald who became
multi-billion high-tech battery company
in just few years we have heard from the
companies who know how to do green
mining
carbon-free Steel
how they can focus creatively on the
critical raw materials we need so much
in Europe and how to push us to the next
level in the electromobility
your companies Mr Prime Minister are
proving that you can be globally
competitive and at the same time highly
sustainable and I think as Mr Alex now
asmani has underscored now we need to
make sure that it would spread these
examples across Europe that we will be
working with all of you to make sure
that it will push over the Finishing
Line be the Chiefs act we start to work
on critical raw materials act that will
be putting down The rules on responsible
mining that we will be working on
pushing Energy prices down and energy
Security in Europe up because this is
exactly what we need to help our
businesses businesses our households and
to consolidate our single Market
president of the European commission
also have underlined just presented her
ideas
to develop the
and work on Net Zero industry Act where
we want to look into the possibilities
how to make the decision making if it
comes to the IP says the important
projects from the common European
interest faster when we would be having
also more expedience assessments of the
stay date and we are going to do all
that to improve the competitiveness of
European companies but also to counter
relocation risks of this companies which
are now in the difficult
situation to get to there we are also
preparing to work on the Europe
sovereignty fund and we are doing all
this to send very clear message to the
European industry we are going to fight
for you to stay and prosper in Europe
Mr Prime Minister if if I look at the
number of the trials your presidency
will be will be facing I think that we
can already now describe your presidency
as very important negotiation presidency
and I just would like to highlight that
we'll be working very closely with you
to make sure that you will have the
utmost success in achieving the
conclusions of this negotiations because
it would allow us to push all these
legislative proposals especially in the
field of uh green deal over the
Finishing Line and make Europe more
more Dynamic and more competitive
if you allow me Madam president to
continue and conclude on very important
point for which the Sweden is
traditionally known any strong supporter
I am talking about the three traits
there are very high ambitious in this
regard
we need to make most of the trade
agreements
for example
we have is Canada but also with UK with
which we are trying hard to sort our
differences
but we are also working very hard to
conclude the agreements with Mexico
chile New Zealand Australia and we like
to work closely with the Swedish
presidency to achieve progress with
India and Indonesia and we also believe
that we need to restart a conversation
about mercosur agreement
and we will do all that together with
making sure that we would find
proper answers to reduce negative side
effects of inflation reduction act and
to face unfair competition which is very
often coming from Chinese massive
subsidies
Madam president one of the issue which
was highlighted by many speakers was the
issue of migration here we in the
European commission are convinced that
with a political will and the hard work
we can finalize migration and Exile
impact we need it now but for sure we
will need it in the future
so Madam president honorable members
dear prime minister and the colleagues
from the Swedish presidency
I think it's quite clear that you are
taking at the Helm of the European Union
at very special crucial time
and I'm sure that thanks to our close
cooperation thanks to traditional
Swedish efficiency Innovative approach
candy spirit and your ambitious agenda
your presidency will be success not only
for you but for whole Europe thank you
very much thank you very much
vice president Chef chovich their
colleagues I know you are eagerly
waiting to vote but we want to hear
after almost three hours of debate from
the Swedish prime minister the current
country holding the rotating presidency
I ask you for a few minutes to listen to
him go ahead or if you have the floor
[Applause]
through tall mom
Commission
Madam president commissioner sefcovich
honorable members
uh it is not every day that I have the
honor of speaking in front of a nearly
full European Parliament
um
my warm thanks for a great deal of very
interesting and thought-provoking
questions
your friendly greetings and critical
comments too I appreciate your clarity
in both questions and answers
as well as your frankness
some parts of
Swedish political parties want to
continue a Swedish electoral campaign in
this house I would like to do that
outside this house
I and the Swedish government have left
the Swedish electoral campaign behind us
now and we are working hard to carry out
important reforms in Sweden and to lead
the European Union student work in the
council going forward
I would like to show respect for our
shared European problems and
opportunities in doing so there are two
domestic policy issues however which are
close to a European matters climate and
the environment and energy
we're not bringing those together in one
Ministry in the Swedish government
because
climate begins and ends in our energy
policy
secondly we are
recasting a Swedish foreign and security
policy to protect Swedish security
through NATO membership that's important
for us but we also believe that that is
of importance for other NATO members
in the 90s
Sweden became a part of the
international
the European democracy through its EU
membership
those of us who saw the economic and
Democratic value of that had to fight a
great deal against those people who
wanted to keep Sweden outside this
Corporation soon Sweden and Finland will
also be part of the International
Community in its security policy
Sweden and Finland are entering NATO 28
of 30 NATO members have already welcomed
us and we place a great deal of value on
that
finally
honorable members
I appreciate this concept of
pride and positive expectation and I
understand the disappointment that has
been felt when it comes to the Schengen
matter
so he didn't understand just like every
other member state does that Bulgarian
Romania are Keen to join Qing and we are
prepared to put that matter on the
agenda
uh we want to consolidate the Balkan
process towards a future EU membership
we've held a very good Western Balkan
Summit in Tirana Sweden's support and is
happy to collaborate to contribute to a
10th sanctions package and uh
clear measures to hold individuals
accountable for the atrocities committed
now in the Ukraine
finally Madam president
yeah we have our motto Greener safer and
Freer all of these three words require
decision making both in the short term
and in the long term
to face immediate problems but also to
rise to long-term challenges we've had
the depth crisis a pandemic vaccines and
through the war and where the EU has
proven time and again that it can manage
crises this was not a given the EU has
impressed when it was most needed crisis
management is necessary however it is
not sufficient on its own
long-term total freedom from fossil
fuels is the key to going green
and long-term and close EU cooperation
with our transatlantic Partners is also
a key to security
long-term competitiveness free trade and
clear Communications from the commission
and Parliament when it comes to matters
of rule of law that is the key to more
freedom Greener safer Freer
discussions thanks
thank you very much prime minister thank
you dear colleagues we will now proceed
to the vote